welcome to another exciting episode of
the movieclips instant trailer review
show I'm Jimmy and I'm James extra both
James on there we are we should just be
James squared
James squared so Jade squirt and I are
here to talk about Hercules with the
rock yeah let's just get right to it you
pointed out this is the first time we're
seeing the rock with the beard
yeah it looks as amazing as I thought it
would you know and it's kind of funny
that MGM is the one that's doing it you
know the bass thumping lion right right
as you will see if you yes it's
foreshadow that's really but this has
been called like the better Hercules
movie so which is obvious with the first
frame yeah you can I mean you can tell
kind of right away
yeah the production value is much higher
let's just like look at this set it's
amazing there's lighting the statues on
fire yeah just just all sorts of awesome
looks incredible yeah it's not coming
out in January I guess I think that's
the most important the most important
qualifier fishing but you know but I'm a
huge rock fan yeah I mean so this is
like three houses that was cool
three-headed dog here yes they fight he
just fights all sorts of crazy yeah
crazy monster crazy living things and I
fell in the rock on Twitter I have for a
while so I like I've seen it
it's done so it's nice to actually see
you know what the movie looks like so
here's that line and that it's a big
that is a long line but that's such a
cool shot and much bigger than the
normal sized lion yeah and so as we're
saying yeah you think that the lines
okay yeah he's working that line as an
element yeah so there's our first real
shot of a grizzly rock mm-hmm and I know
he's Dwayne Johnson but yeah I mean like
that name is just but he's the rock he's
playing Hercules you know he's come on
but you know it's really cool I think to
see his career really take off even more
I mean like this is arguably like the
first big like solo role that he's had a
lot of kind of late additions to you
know established franchise like most
notably fast and furious right so this
is like the first his first before a
really into his own movie franchise
almost yeah depending on how well this
does but he's obviously really popular
he's really funny he's a great action
star mm-hmm I think I think this movie
looks really good yeah I did too
there's another great shot he's going
he's almost blonde yeah that's crazy
right and I'm I'm happy to see a like a
Greek mythology movie that isn't heavily
CGI like 300 or more I mean I mean like
it's sad but we have to compare it to
the count ones yeah yeah I don't wanna I
don't wanna like bash on that but I mean
but this one has the rock yeah this one
I was a rock yeah and if that wasn't
enough if that wasn't enough so that's
the only thing about this movie yeah I
never said that Ratner is directing
right which could go either way you mean
it could be like an awesome sort of rush
hour s movie or it could be Tower Heist
terrorized again that's exactly right
you took the words out of my mouth but I
mean even like the trailer for this
movie it's just such a it's treated with
so much more class than the other I mean
you know it you're gonna get whenever
from this trailer you're gonna get the
rock fighting huge oversized animals no
I'm not crazy I'm crazy about this title
treatment yeah it's like kind of like
80s hair band
yeah yeah but I mean this shot yeah so
Hercules comes out in July mm-hmm middle
the summer movie season
yeah look at that I mean come on yeah
look guys no heart it's his arm has a
difference of codes yes is so big yeah
it's amazing it's huge
I and I have a sequence of him making
that lion and - a helmet oh my gosh that
would be I want to see how it's that
would be amazing sir Achilles trailer I
think it looks great I think comes out
in July yeah middle of the summer movie
season so they're obviously you know
they're bettin betting big on this yeah
pretty sure it's gonna be really well
pretty sure um and like I said I think I
think it looks really cool yeah
I'm excited for it I love Greek
mythology stuff and this looks great so
there you have it
James squared and I think it looks great
yeah so let us know what you think is
this gonna be better than the thalamus
really is this gonna be the best
rendition of Hercules that you've seen
it's a better than Kevin Sorbo I don't
know I don't know yeah that point anyway
let us know in the comments below and
for movie clips I'm Jimmy I'm James
thanks for watching